sí muy buenos días pues esta reunión
está por comenzar y hay bastantes temas
sobre la mesa el primero hacer las
relaciones con eeuu justamente cuando yo
bailen pues se ha dicho en su discurso
de política exterior que quiere volver a
reconstruir los lazos con sus aliados
también van a hablar de la soberanía
europea esto es decir a la seguridad del
continente que para angela merkel pues
debe ser asegurada por la otan mientras
que para emanuel el marco en realidad la
idea es que europa pues se pueda
garantizar ella sola esta seguridad y
derecho esto nos hace recordar cuando se
realizó esta misma reunión en 2019 y
justamente antes de esa reunión en ese
momento de manuel marco había dicho que
la otan estaba de muerte cerebral algo
que no le había gustado para nada la
canciller alemana el tercer tema que van
a discutir durante este día es el de
armamento es un tema bastante delicado
ahí también porque ambos países
iniciaron un proyecto conocido como es
cap que es el sistema de combate
para el futuro un proyecto que comenzó
en el 2017 pero que hasta ahora pues no
ha podido avanzar de verdad no ha tenido
un bueno progreso porque ha tenido
muchos inconvenientes por una parte para
que se vote el presupuesto de este
proyecto por parte de ambos países y
también por cuestiones industriales pero
bueno la idea es que hablar de este tema
justamente antes de que angela merkel
pues se deje de ser la canciller en
septiembre